o pessoal de 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer esta questão do iraque decidiu
aumentar um pouco o tamanho da zaga nos
preços a folha a3 se vocês não tiverem
podem usar duas folhas a4 pois é só
juntar com cola que vocês vão ver um
tutorial aí consegue fazer mas fica
melhor se for já estiver em ok e pronto
aqui como vocês podem ver em uma cadeira
com três camas mas só dois equiparam
este aqui é só por uma questão de
estrutura e claro quanto vocês arma tem
que usar alguns proteção porque pode o
tiro bater na parede voltar atrás eu
acho que aguentar até então sempre usava
proteção como se fosse um bom estoque só
nesse esporte
agora por elásticos supõe relações
depois porém os óculos que este sistema
normal para enxergar e usar balas topel
na marcha é isso então bora lá e vão
sair eu vou para lá atrás só tem uma
bala e salvamos aos testes
então vamos lá só o primeiro tem que
usar uma folha a3 para fazer uma rifa
caso vocês não tenham folhas a três como
eu disse no início é só juntar duas
folhas a4 que vão ter uma folha com o
tamanho de uma a três depois tem que ir
lá como foi a 3 também para fazer um
tubo e rola com cuidado justen e prendam
usando fita um então cola e agora estou
mais adepto da cola porque o acampamento
fica muito melhor e aí esta parte de
rifa e de estudo vão servir só de
referência para os tubos que vou fazer
depois ok para aprender uma parte à
outra e concluí cola dentro do tubo por
lá e fui pra eficaz e pronta agora vou
começar a fazer os tubos
vou começar a fazer os tubos do cano e
vou no lar uma folha com o tamanho a3
agora se vocês quiserem fazer mais
resistente pode juntar duas folhas a3
enrolar do mesmo modo que vocês viram
agora eu não tenha folhas atrás de outra
cor então eu decidi juntar duas a quatro
para mostrar como é que se faz e também
porque vai ficar mais bonita usar duas
cores e vejam do modo que eu vou enrolar
o que não é quando do outro lado quem as
lê
naquela parte grande mas sim da parte
mais pequenina aí
deste modo porque não precisar deste
estudo muito grande
agora vou fazer
os canos que eu tenho aqui três tubos
grandes vão juntar um ao outro estou
usar qual a quinta estou por cola no
outro e para que os tubos não fiquem
todos juntos eu coloquei lá uma rifa
para criar um intervalo
cortem presente com cinco centímetros e
depois junto em 33
vamos tentar fazer isso cinco vezes
cortem mais três domínios mas este com
15 centímetros junto do mesmo modo não
tem portanto vocês vão pondo os tubinhos
contra a mesa antiga escola sec para
ficarem tudo alinhado quando estiver
tudo seco é só vocês garanta definir com
os instintos circularem no pedaço com
kings entende os pedacinhos seguintes
vão em forma de escada que é eu seja o
segmento ficar por cima vai sempre
divulgando de alimento para trás
ou seja tem que ficar possível como
empunhadura verdadeira marca instinto já
em uma das extremidades do campo e
ponham bastante cola aqui uma vez que a
conexão é pequena e tem ficar mesmo
resistente conecta é nas duas partidas e
por cima encontra mesa pra ficar tudo
minado
vamos satisfazer duas rifas e depois tem
como titular deste modo para fazer os
dois kits
vejam que dobra sua irmã envio à justiça
o tamanho de uma extremidade e já está
mais ou menos 827 fiquem sacrifica tudo
andar livremente a cair depois tem que
fazer mais um gatilho uma vez que para
duas vezes mas este aqui é ligeiramente
mais cumprido o primeiro
agora vocês podem fazer como estou a
fazer não podem pôr os dois do mesmo
tamanho
só que dá mais jeito se não for maior
que o outro aqui
veja aqui como funciona é agora para
explicar mais eficaz tem cortar
necessitando de 45 grave
isso vai ajudar bastante na parte de
tirar o que estamos aí e vai colocar e
colocar dentro para ficar aquela parte
mais forte agora fazer uma proteção para
os dedos e se não me engano eu guardo
guarda mato e vejo que estou no brasil e
foi em forma assim mais ou menos em
dizê-lo limpinho cole depois prendendo
contra o cano caiu depois vou cortar
esta parte das rifas mesmo no final
só que eu não gostei no tutorial mas
vocês conseguem ver na parte inicial e
final do vídeo como ficou caí
vou fazer agora parte da colônia
por isso vou juntar duas rifas depois
mais duas rifas
se vocês quiserem podem ir lá jornal e
fica assim mais limpas maiores aqui se
vocês quiserem fazer umas comprinhas
maior hoje que o fez ter humildade e vou
começar a rolar aquela caneca ética a
salvar
só que eu comprei conferir a fábrica da
cerveja não se preocupa em ensinar uns
detalhes que não sendo o tutorial
desnecessário fui fazendo como vocês
podem ver o carinho é eu sei fazer o
tutorial só não vale a pena
simples aí eu estou agora pretende de
picolé é isso
aquela parte dos campos
os pistões bater lá com muita força e
estraga um papel com o tempo
agora neste ponto tem de lá vai aumentar
bastante resistência e uma coisa que
aumenta também bastante resistência é
essa super cola que estou usando agora é
só se forem do brasil é o super bonder
em portugal existem cola e também super
cola normais aqui só porque ela escolas
instantâneas
agora vou fazer os pistons por linkedin
decola nesta parte da fifa e vou cortar
um patrocínio igual àquela pequena que
eu dobrei e vou colar ali no lado oposto
vou usar elásticos desde pequeninos
normais do escritório encaixei lá e
depois prende com fita
agora você já vou usar cola não tem que
usar fita nesta parte porque a cola com
os impactos podem desprender só cair mas
a fita não é como se fosse uma corda
atada agora como é que vocês prendem os
outros elásticos é bastante simples
tem que ajustar o tamanho da fifa porque
a partir dali na extremidade que sobrou
é bastante frágil local e tem que ficar
assim mãe tudo para conseguir bater nas
balas e ir embora o país ficará sem
frouxa foi num não vai funcionar cair
vejam como esponjas elásticos tem que
passar por aquela para uma mãe dos dois
campos lembra que por lá uma rifa para
deixar o espaçamento foi mesmos
totalmente pensado para conseguir
colocar depois do relato e vejam que eu
cortei a frente como tinha ido e foi
encaixar outra elástica e agora é só
carregar a arma já que é bastante
símbolos já está já que os detidos com
tamanho diferente do sol está feito
o estado você tiver alguma sugestão de
alguns projetos e deixar nos comentários
é isso que vem ajudar o canal é só
deixaram lá e tal até a próxima quarta
espanha